We are in the middle of a global hundred year
pandemic.
The highest unemployment since 1948, which
is the first year that unemployment was tracked
under the modern system, the largest nationwide
protests that we've seen in a very long time,
these over police brutality.
And one of the highest numbers of horrifying
police brutality incidents that this country
has seen in such a short period of time in
decades.
And Donald Trump set a new record for himself,
sending out two hundred tweets and read tweets
in a single day on Friday.
The president cannot lead and instead he's
tweeting from behind his bunker fact base,
which track this tweeted, we we're wrapping
the day at 200 tweets for Donald Trump, most
for the account ever, period at 468 tweets.
It's the most in a week for Trump during his
presidency and 74 tweets between eight and
nine a.m., the most in an hour ever.
As you can see there, if you're looking at
the chart along with me, June 5th, surpassing
January 22nd with two hundred total tweets
and read tweets the most of any day during
Donald Trump's presidency, Donald Trump is
now tweeting, by the way, from behind two
miles of fencing and barricades.
Much of it installed over the last week as
Bunker Boy, as many are calling him, further
isolates himself from reality.
So there are about five or six different relevant
layers here.
First of all, I'm not president of the United
States.
I just have this show.
I don't have time to tweet nearly 200 times
in a day on a day where I tweet a lot, where
I feel like I probably tweeted too much today.
I might tweet 15 times.
Maybe if I do a bunch of read tweets, maybe
20 times.
And and I'm not president of the United States.
That's the first story.
Secondly, this day, Friday included seventy
four tweets in an hour between eight and nine
a.m.
Eastern Time.
That is more than a tweet per hour, a tweet
per minute for an entire hour.
That is an unhealthy level of social media
use, which raises further questions on its
own.
Number three, again, we're in the middle of
a global hundred year pandemic.
Highest unemployment since 1948.
A huge nationwide protests, huge police brutality
issues.
And Donald Trump sets a record for himself,
tweeting and retweeting 200 times in a single
day.
That doesn't make sense.
We need a leader who can lead and do things.
Now, some of you will say, well, Trump can't
lead, so we're better off with him just sitting
around tweeting.
But the tweets are actually doing damage.
It's not like the tweets are neutral.
He's still doing damage by tweeting.
Number four, Trump just got done attacking
Twitter and he's using it more than ever.
Why not get away from Twitter if Twitter is
treating him so terribly?
Because he simply can't.
And that gets us to the clinical aspects of
this.
I spoke to a couple of mental health professionals
over the weekend, and they all had a similar
version of the same thing to say, which is
essentially that Donald Trump's behavior,
as we now see it on Twitter, is compulsive
and obsessive.
And it's a sort of decompensation of sorts.
His behavior is the type of behavior that,
you know, if your coworker at Best Buy is
behaving this way, if your coworker at an
accounting firm is behaving this way, you'd
probably go and talk to H.R. and say something's
not right here.
It's manic behavior.
It's compulsive behavior.
You might have some kind of an intervention.
There might be a psychiatric evaluation done
at a certain point.
That's the type of behavior that we're seeing
from Donald Trump.
Now, one last thing you might have noticed
that I didn't go through and read individual
tweets of Donald Trump during this segment.
And there's no shortage of tweets that I could
have read.
We are past the significance of any one of
Donald Trump's tweets in general.
Now, if Donald Trump tweets something that's
specifically newsworthy or actionable, if
it relates to some new policy that his administration
is going to be rolling out, if it's a direct
attack on an ally, if there is some kind of
particular relevance, I will tell you what
the content of Trump's tweets is.
But what happened on Friday, 200 tweets and
read tweets, it's just erratic behavior.
And I don't want to glorify or lend credence
to any one message that Trump sent by actually
reading the tweets.
It was a combination of lies and smears and
attacks and bragging self-congratulation,
retweeting right wing trash and conspiracy
theories.
That's what it was.
That's the summary.
The individual tweets really were irrelevant.
They didn't communicate any particular policy.
They were mostly smears of other people.
So I am not going to give them more credibility
or attention than they need.
Other than to point out 200 tweets in a day
is bonkers.
And this is the president of the United States.
That is where we will leave it.
And certainly, if Trump does actually tweet
something relevant to policy, I will tell
you what
it is, Fearnot.